الرجل الثاني في حركه النهضه الاخوانيه
نور الدين البحيري رهن الايقاف من قبل
الاجهزه الامنيه ومعه رجل الاعمال التونسي
المثير للجدل كمال لطيف والناشط السياسي
خيام التركي وغيره من رجال الاعمال
والقضاه والكوادر الامنيه السلطات
القضائيه التونسيه تتكتم عن اسباب
الايقافات فيما بعد التقارير الاعلاميه
تتحدث عن تهام تتعلق بالتامر على امن
الدوله هذه اللقافات ويعتبرها مسار فعلي
انطلاق فعليه لمسار المحاسبه باعتبار بطء
هذا المسار باعتبار الخطوات التي لم تكن
بالشكل المطلوب خلال سنه ونص الفارطه هي
مجموعه من اللقافات حسب التهم تتعلق
بالتامر على امن الدوله وهذا ربما ثابت من
خلال نوعيه الايقافات نوعيه
الاشخاصين فقط ان الشعب يريد المحاسبه
ولا بد من محاسبه هؤلاء
كل هؤلاء ولا استثناء لاحد مهما كان
ويسر الرئيس سعيد على ضروره المحاسبه
كمطلب شعبي بينما تندد احزاب المعارضه
بالايقافات معتبره اياها تضيقا على
الرافدين لمسار الخامس والعشرين من يوليو
ثمه خيط فاصل ورفيع جدا بين المحاسبه وبين
تصفيه الحسابات او تصفيه الخصوم المحاسبه
هو المطلب الاكبر للشعب التونسي بل هو
المطلب الذي جعل التونسيون على الاقل في
25 جويليه يصطفون وراء رئيس الجمهوريه
عمليه المحاسبه كانت خطاها بطيئه جدا
والرئيس قيس سعيد فسر الامر على اساس ان
القضاء او جسم القضائي في تونس يستعصي على
القيام بدوره او يستعصي على الاصلاح ويؤكد
متابعون ان دائره الايقافات ستتوسع
مستقبلا خاصه مع اعاده فتح عدد من الملفات
على غرار الارهاب والتسفير والاغتيالات
السياسيه يؤكد جلو المتابعين للمشهد
التونسي ان تواتر الايقافات الاخيره فيما
يشبه تس اقط تع الدومينو ستعقبه وتتبعات
قضائيه تجسيدا لمبدا المحاسبه وتحقيق
العداله والقطع مع الافلات من العقاب طيله
عشريه الاخوان وليد عبد الله العربيه
تونس